hey guys Pete here so some interesting
news came out about the Twin Peaks
season 3 the return DVD boxset that's
gonna be coming out and even though we
don't have a pre-order link yet we do
know in the DVD blu-ray is gonna be
coming out it'll be out on December 5th
which we've heard already about a month
ago now David Lynch announced it on
Twitter and it's come out and all the
press but for the last month we
basically been wondering what else is
going to be on there besides just the 18
episodes with no official announcement
and nothing else to go off of we've just
been wondering what happens when they
make DVD sets like this or blu-ray is in
order to release that they have to give
it a rating so that people know who it's
appropriate for obviously the TV shows
aired so everyone knows what that's all
about this means that when something
like this comes out we can find out
what's on it before it's officially
announced because the bodies who do the
ratings sometimes actually say what they
put a rating on so I've seen this with
Game of Thrones each year that happens
we find out a little bit about what's on
the DVD and pretty much every show now
that I think about it and so yeah this
happens the British Board of Film
classification reported the following
titles and run times for what's going to
be on the DVD on their website so that
I'll give you the titles of the
different things the first one is a
bloody finger in your mouth which is 25
minutes in 43 seconds next one is a pot
of boiling oil which would be 36 minutes
and 58 seconds long do not pick up
hitchhikers 25 minutes and 39 seconds
see you on the other side dear friend
2849 tell it Martin 27:57
the man with the grey elevated hair 28
27 2 blue balls 23 13 bad binoculars 27
and one and the number of completion 28
minutes and 4 seconds long all of these
segments have been rated age
is 15 and up except for see you on the
other side dear friend and bad
binoculars which were rated 12 enough
now the names are obviously interesting
it's sort of like the titles of season 3
were where you might think it's one
thing but it's probably something else
the only ones we've actually heard from
people was Dale Cooper obvious he said
the number of completion and Jerry Horne
said bad binoculars so we can't tie
these to any specific scenes that might
be extended material for those and even
the two that we have seen in the show I
wouldn't make that connection right away
that it's going to be exactly about
those parts instead I think it's safe to
say that these could be literally about
anything and while it's fun to speculate
I'm not even gonna do that here because
it's just there's really no good reason
to do it it won't be right I think
that's really honestly the truth here at
the festival of disruption we found out
a little bit more that there's not just
going to be season 3 stuff on this DVD
set but there's actually gonna be stuff
from the first season as well which will
make everyone pretty excited I think we
found out that there's going to be two
episodes of something called behind the
red curtain each of those are gonna be
roughly 30 minutes in length and they're
both going to contain additional
material from season one as mentioned at
the beginning of this there still is not
a pre-order available for this yet I
don't think that's necessarily weird it
would be nice if they put it up though
since it's coming I mean we're not that
far away but that we do have a whole
month yet but as soon as one does come
out I'll put it in the description of
this video and you can check back to see
when that happens I'll definitely post
it on my Twitter account as soon as I
hear anything about that we are getting
close to the release of the final
dossier as of today there's exactly two
weeks left for that I do want to remind
you that I'm giving one of those away on
my patreon account I'll post a link here
that you can follow and learn more about
that but basically everyone who signed
up for my patreon on the 31st once
patreon does its thing on the fur
and everyone gets their you know gets
verified for that month or whatever then
I will pick out one name from the list
and I'll send someone a copy of the book
I'll be doing recaps on that or reviews
on that I guess and I'm really excited
about that as well there's one other
news as related to the big festival of
disruption that just happened I may do a
separate video about that there's not a
whole lot of Twin Peaks related stuff
but definitely a lot of David Lynch fans
and fans of the series stuff that'll get
you going I mean like the you know kandi
Sandy and Mandy showed up to help during
the question and answers people asked
David Lynch a lot of questions of course
he didn't answer a lot of them I wasn't
there personally but it looks like it
was a great time and it could be an
interesting video I'll have to go
through what I have but more importantly
my season one rewatch will be picking up
again tomorrow I am working on that
video now patrons over on my patreon
decided that that's what they wanted to
see next and that's what I'm doing I was
traveling this weekend because I had
some things to take care of but I'm back
at home now for the next three months
and I'll be doing all eight of those
episodes in season one to see how it
goes so definitely get involved with
that if you want
I'm looking into live streaming I was
thinking about doing a Q&A for each one
of those first episodes of the first
season so maybe let me know what you
think about that in the comments that's
it for now check back tomorrow for the
next video please like this one if you
enjoyed it make sure you subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already I'm
working on mr. robot videos all the time
because I'm really into that series and
it's looking really good for season 3
make sure you follow me on my social
media accounts Twitter Instagram and
Facebook thanks for watching guys I'll
talk to you soon